[Music]
they call me terrorist radical zealot
because I obey the ancient laws of my
people to creep and punish those who do
not because I do not forgive the old
people for taking the life of my father
and his father and his father before him
a thousand years of war between us will
not be forgotten
it's our
[Music]
everybody is Charlie it is on if you
didn't realize what's going on here leap
aces Ronan the accuser is coming back
for Captain Marvel
so Ronan in Korath from guardians of the
galaxy will be in the Captain Marvel
movie but the reason why they're alive
is because the movie takes place 20
years ago so I'll explain what's going
on here if you're new to the channel
there's new Infinity Ward giveaway stuff
going on I'll explain at the end of the
video be sure to subscribe to get
everything
so a lot of you have already realized
that there are a couple of continuity
errors with what happened during the
guardians of the galaxy movie the Kree
Nova war that he's talking about during
that clip in the kree-skrull war that's
going to be happening during the Captain
Marvel movie so you have two completely
different space Wars Ronan talks about
the Kree Nova war during guardians of
the galaxy that he is seeking vengeance
for going back a thousand years this
thousand-year war where a peace treaty
was signed at the end of that he was so
disgusted with the Kree because he's so
dogmatic and such a fundamentalist that
he renounced his citizenship and his
title of supreme accuser of the Kree
accuser Corps and took a space fleet off
to start his own personal war against
the Nova Corps that's when he sought the
alliance with Thanos and we all saw that
play out the way that it did so he's
dead in present day but twenty years ago
because Kree are a little more
physically resilient than humans they
live a little bit longer it's not that
long ago in his lifespan so just a
little while ago he was embroiled in the
kree-skrull war which is what we're
gonna see play out during the Captain
Marvel movie what I'm hoping that they
do is they just sort of slot in the
kree-skrull war as part of the larger
war that he's talking about in guardians
of the galaxy that goes back a thousand
years so that it doesn't completely
break the continuity but they might have
to retcon a couple minor things about
guardians of the galaxy which i don't
think that too many people will care
about like as long as Captain Marvel is
a cool movie and as long as Ronan's
performance in the character end up
being awesome I think that people will
be totally fine it's a really cool thing
about this is that we have Jude Law's
Marvel who's a really important
character passes his powers genetically
to Captain Marvel but he was a member of
the Kree military he was just a normal
kernel in their space fleet Ronan's
accuser Corps is kind of like the
military police so technically the
didn't serve together but they probably
knew each other but here's the really
cool thing about Ronan remember he's a
hardcore fundamentalist he's a blue
skinned Kree and they're kind of like
the aristocracy amongst their species
the pink-skin Kree are kind of like the
underclass or the muggles if you want to
make a Harry Potter reference so you
have to imagine that Ronan probably
thought that Marvel was an abomination
but the whole reason why Marvel became a
big character is because the Kree
supreme intelligence found out a long
time ago that they had hit a genetic
evolutionary dead end he started to
encourage the Kree to interbreed with
other alien races to quote-unquote
freshen the gene pool so you have to
imagine that Ronan probably was not down
with this like all about the pure blood
like the Targaryen Zin The Game of
Thrones series wedding brother to sister
to keep their dragon seed blood pure so
that they could maintain their ability
to dragon bond or the other Harry Potter
reference you know pure Bloods versus
muggles so just imagine that Ronan is
the most hardcore of pureblood Crees
with all the character traits that come
with a person like that we don't
actually know if they're gonna do the
Supreme intelligence in the movie but in
the comics what happened is the whole
reason that Marvel went to Planet Earth
is because the supreme intelligence
wanted access to psionic abilities and
felt like they're genetically similar
pink Kree race could interbreed with the
human to gain access to those powers
because Marvel was available he felt
like he was a good candidate so he sent
Marvel to earth and that was sort of the
beginning of how Marvel found himself on
planet earth the reason why Ronan was
important to that storyline is is
because he wanted to take over earth and
turn it into a Kree military outpost
where they could just resupply their
ships while they were busy fighting all
the scrolls obviously if there had been
a giant Kree invasion 20 years ago on
planet Earth
Nick Fury would probably be talking
about a little bit more like he says the
last time I trusted someone I lost an
eye last time I trusted someone I lost
an eye we know there's gonna be some
elements of scrolls secret invasion
pretending to be other people because
that's probably how he lost his eye just
one person who's a scroll who's someone
he trusts who then takes his eye out
that he barely fights off I've already
done an Ironman Easter Egg video because
he talks about project Pegasus
I'll link that at the end of this but
that's the base where you see the
tesseract at the beginning of the
Avengers movie Howard Stark and Nick
Fury were instrumental in building that
that was built after the Triskelion but
it was their secret facility that was
formed to investigate we know what they
call phenomena beyond the range of
conventional scientific understanding so
any alien tech anything crazy that they
didn't totally understand which you know
is where we get to Captain Marvel
because that's prime Captain Marvel
territory because you're talking about
alien invasion Marvel the kree-skrull
war and probably the device the psyche
magnetron that gives Captain Marvel her
powers so they did say they were
changing her origin story a little bit
but I wouldn't be surprised if they
still have a lot of elements from that
comic book origin so just imagine a
version of the Ronan plot from the
kree-skrull war where he was trying to
take over planet Earth
marvel's initial mission he was sent on
by the Kree supreme intelligence and
they sort of blending in elements of the
MCU the movies always tend to be really
simple so you just have to imagine that
earth is sort of this bystander in the
kree-skrull war and it gets caught
between these two big races in Marvel
tries to help them out but in doing so
there's that big accident that gives
Captain Marvel her powers
we actually got a look at what her
costume is probably gonna look like at
the end of the film on this magazine
cover notice that it's more silver than
gold highlights here so maybe that
changes during Avengers 4 but this does
seem like the most accurate
representation of her Captain Marvel
costume in that movie so it sounds like
all this concept art for Avengers 4
means that there are some small costume
tweaks that make it a little bit more
like comic book Captain Marvel because
in the comics it is more gold than
silver I'm just really excited to see
them redeem Ronan the accuser is a
villain he's a cool character in the
comics and Lee pace is a fantastic actor
I felt like he did a pretty good job
during guardians of the galaxy but it
was still kind of during the era of Bad
Marvel villains I feel like they're
slowly on the path to correcting that
but speaking of guardians of the galaxy
I know you've all been asking me to do a
video update about that because that
movies sort of in limbo but it's good
news bad news situation so I'll do a
video for that next that should be up in
the next couple of hours like I said
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last big video Pierce Smith please email
me on the about page of my youtube
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new marble click here to learn all
about the venom trilogy and carnage that
Sony just confirmed and click here for
that Ironman Captain Marvel Easter egg
scene thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]